طبعا ونحن نشاهد هذه الصور لخطاب يلقيه
منذ قليل القاه منذ قليل الرئيس الاوكراني
فولوديمير زيلينسكي طبعا اخر تلك
التصريحات كان عن الناتو الذي اعلن تصميمه
على دعم اوكرانيا وجهود روسيا ستفشل وايضا
كان هناك عده مواقف للخارجيه الامريكيه
ركزت فيها على انه العلاقات مع موسكو يمكن
ان تعود لطبيعتها بعد انتهاء الصراع
باوكرانيا وبانه العاصمه الامريكيه لن
توقف امدادات الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا طالما
استمرت الحرب وان هذه الحرب يمكن ان تتوقف
غدا اذا امر بوتين بذلك كمان هناك مواقف
روسيه صادره عن نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي الذي شدد على انه يجب ابعاد
التهديدات عن الحدود الروسيه وبان الحرب
باوكرانيا ستنتهي بالنصر او يمكن
الاتفاق كان بموضوع النصر كان الرئيس
زيلينسكي بخطابه امس قد اعتبر انه عام
2023 سيكون عاما للنصر وهو الذي نشاهده
امامنا
يلقي خطابا او يعني يتحدث الى احدى النساء
ربما حسب ما هو الظاهر انها والده احدى
احد الضحايا الذين سقطوا في هذه الحرب
طبعا نذكر بانه اليوم هو ذكرى مرور
عام واحد على هذه الحرب وهو الان يكرم
ضحايا الحرب من الجيش الاوكراني